I THOUGHT HE WAS JUST TREMENDOUS
ABLE TO CHIP IT AHEAD.
ANGLED TO O
>> Rick: ANZE KOPITAR PLAYING IN
HIS  LEG OF
KOPITAR OVER TO IAFALLO.
CLEARS THE ZONE.DE.
DURZI LET IT GO.
BYFIELD.
HERE'S ANDERSSON. K DOWN
KOPITAR.
BROKEN UP NEATLY BY LINDHOLM.
BACKHAND PASS TO GAUDREAU LAT
ALEXANDER EDLER TO KEMPE.
AND TO IAFALLO.
HE DOES WHA UP THE BOARDS.
MOORE IS THERE TO WORK IT
THROUGH CENTRE ICPUCK.
KYLINGTON MAYBE DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND PUTTING THE PUCK ON
ANDERSON IN THE FAC
HANIFIN.
HANIFIN
THE SE PETERSEN.
LEFT LEG THIS TIME.
THAT'S BLOCKED.
BOUNCING TO THTHN LOOKED AROUND.
HE K K
CROWD DOESN'T LIKE THAT NO CALL.
SECOND UNIT JOINING HIHI
MATTHEW W
REBOUND.
BYFIELD.
FEEDS IT UP THE BOARDS FOR
JORDAN
OFF A DEFENCEMAN AND WIDE OF TH
SATURDAY.
KINGS IN WINNIPEG TO
MAKES A PLAY TO THE SIDE OF THE
GOAL TO MONAHAN.
DEFLECTION.
IT'S HARD
STORY HERE.
IT'S HARD TO TELL.
>> K
STICK, SOMETHING LIKE THAT
ANYWAYS.
>> Rick: THERE'S A STOP BY
MARKSTROM ON ALOW.
WATCH THAT BEAUTIFUL
WILL START FOR LOS AN
MARKSTROM THE SAVE. BY ANDERS
SHOOTER FOR LOS ANGELES.
>> Kelly: AND YOU CAN JUST SEE
TERRIFIC SET